[Müzik]
gerçekten çok ilginç bir kavram evde
oluş değişim kimileri için sürrealist
kimleri için çok gerçekçi küreleri için
yani benim için çok renkli kimlerin
içinde çok cansız
benim için metaforce tam olarak ortalama
Duran yeşili renk
teknoloji anlamına geliyor
Şimdi tanışalım Tabii ki ben buraya
gelip de sizinle normal bir şekilde
tanışmayacağım Yani şöyle ben Karan
karatejimde 11 sınıf aileyi öğrencisiyim
şu kulübünün başkanıyım bu kulübünün
liderliğini yapıyorum şuradayım
buradayım gibi değil Ben çünkü her
şeyden önce bir kız kardeşlerim bir
ablayıvereyim bir kız çocuğuyum daha
sonraki öğrenciyim bir arkadaşım Bunlar
benim için çok daha önce geliyor çünkü
bunlar bizim Aslında insani
özelliklerimiz toplumda hepimizin farklı
rolleri var her zaman değişiyor
Şimdi şöyle Öncelikle Ben konuşmama
maalesef ülkemizde birkaç hafta önce
yaşanan depremlerle ilgili başlamak
istiyorum Öncelikle Umuyorum ki hepiniz
iyisinizdir Çünkü kimlerimiz direk
olarak kimlerimize dolaylı olarak çok
etkilendi bundan Ama ben şuna Kesinlikle
katılıyorum ki en son umutlar ölür ve
gerçekten de her felaket sonrası
tarihlerde tarihler boyunca insanların
anlaşabileceği tek şey Tüm bu
felaketlerin yalnızca bilim ve
teknolojinin ışığında yenilebilecek ve
gerçekten en sonuncular oluyor bence çok
Bu açıdan manalı bir laf oluyor Ben de
bunun kendi Popstar ve adına bir projemi
gerçekleştirdim ve şu anda biz okula
Bizim okulumuza gelen misafir
öğrencilere akran eğitimini sağlıyoruz
bunun dışında ben kendim bu işin
teknolojik boyutu ile ilgili fizik
boyutuyla
yani araştırma haline getiriyorum ve
Umuyorum ki bunu başarıyla yapmak
isteyenlerde de birleştirebileceğim
hayatım boyunca gerçekten çok fazla
hayatımda dediğim lise
hayatım boyunca bir sürü projeye
gerçekleştirdim kulüpte çalıştım
organizasyonlar yürüttüm ama benim için
daha yani her zaman daha ön planda olmak
seninle ilgili Yani sen ne olacak bilmez
alanlarının hayatımıza entegrasyonuyla
ilgili oldu bunlar benim için gerçekten
çok daha büyük önem taşırdı ve ben
aslında biz hayatıma en azından on
robotikle başladım diyebilirim Biz her
sefer robotik takımla birlikte eserse
yanında dünyanın en Prestij robotik
turnuvalarından birine katılım
sağlıyoruz ve geçen sene ilk senemizde
Rukiye All Stars ödülünü aldık bu sene
de ben kendim bireysel olarak
seçildim bu benim için gerçekten çok
önemli Şimdi ben size bunları böyle
cv'imi döker gibi bütçesine anlattım ama
bunu Aslında arka planda yatan benim
için çok farklı bir olay şimdi şurada
görebileceğiniz simli ceketli adam
christmack first olsun ve Biz kendisiyle
gerçekten Geçen hafta bossforce videomda
çok önemli bir konuşmaya imza attık
robotla ilgili bana birkaç soru
soruyorum ve ben de işte robotu
anlatıyorum şu kodu yazdık bu mekanik
vesaire şeklinde ve bana
dedim Ondan sonra dedi ki; Bu bir emek
Bu bir duyarlı profesyonellik Bu bir
takım bir şey ama bu bir robot değildi
dedi O benim gerçekten çok hoşuma gitti
Çünkü
teknoloji ile yani tomorroflaşan
dünyamızın aslında ne kadar insanla
bağlı insana bağlı bir şey olduğunu
bizde bir kere daha anlattı insan
kavramı Bence aslında şu iki şey ee kork
ilişkiler ve özgür iradenizle aldığımız
aksiyonlar dolayısıyla da Bunu teknoloji
ile bütünleştirmek benim için çok önemli
Burada gördüğünüz iki kavram Güneşin
professionalizm ve kooperation yani
rekabet içerisindeki dayanışma ve her
zaman herkeste herkesten öğrenme
durumuna açık olmak gerçekten ben
teknoloji ile ilgilenen veya ileride
teknolojinin içinde olacak olan
insanların bu iki kavramı
özel önemli olduğunu düşünüyorum Çünkü
biz Hani robot yani sahada da Yeri geldi
konunun çalışmıyor diye birbirimize
bağırdık Yeri geldi görme engelliler
için projemiz dernekler tarafından
destekleneceğiz Sevindik Ee yani Şöyle
ki aslında biz bir salonunda tüm
takımlara yardım ettik ve robotlarımız
orada çarpışırken biz bu gerçekten bence
çok önemli çünkü teknolojinin
evrimleştiği dünyamızda gerçekten
rekabet çok arttı Ama bunun yanında
sebebi etik değerlerimizi insani duygu
ve düşüncelerimizi asla kaybetmememiz
gerektiğini bildiğinde göstermiş oldu
devam edecek olursak İlhan şimdi İlhan
başımın altına ailecek bir fotoğrafınızı
koymuş olmamız olmam Çok klişe geliyor
olabilir Size şu anda Ama gerçekten de
benim bu yolculuğumda kesinlikle annem
ve babamın çok ayrı bir yeri olduğunu
düşünüyorum ben yani her daim Kendi
Ayakları üzerinde duran tuttuğunu
koparan ve özgürlük peşinde koşan bir
kız olmamı kendi kararlarını kendim
almamı Ve mantık çerçevesi içinde
değerlendirmeme destekleyen insanlar
oldular kendileri de zaten çok değerli
ben
dolunayın ilerleyen insanlar oldukları
düşünüyorum Şimdi de ben bunu yine
buraya size aile hikay
imi anlattım Tabii ki de benim
teknolojiyle bağlantıdan bağlayacağım
Ben daha 12 yaşındayken bile Annemle
babam kulak burun boğaz doktorları
onlarla birlikte o zamanlar Doktor
olmayı çok
istiyor onlarla birlikte yazın
ve bu benim için çok önemlidir Hani bir
gün benim anestezi çok ilgimi çekti
[Müzik]
hayata doğru ayarlıyorlar Sonuçta bir
ölüm kalım
dozunu nasıl ayarlıyorlar Şimdi ben de
bunun için ta o yaştan teknoloji ile
ilgili bir şey yaptım ve bunu doğru
dozunu ayarlayan bir Yapay Zeka
uygulaması geliştirerek bir yarışmaya
başlamıştım ve Hani bu aslında benim
için şunu gösteriyor Bu kadar küçük
yaştaki ben o zaman 12
bu kadar küçük yaştaki insanların bile
her türlü soruna çözümü teknolojide
bulmaları gerçekten bizim için dünyanın
ne kadar metamorfozlaştığını gösteriyor
bunu gerçekten yaparken yani teknoloji
dünyamızı değiştirirken herkesin farklı
rolleri var
[Müzik]
Salatada çalışarak yapıyor bir başkası
teknolojileri bir şirketin CEO'su olarak
yapıyor ama önemli olan kendimize
Aslında bu metamorfozun neresinde
bulundunuz Finans kaskının dönüşüm
kitabını hepiniz okumuşsunuzdur ve hani
biz Tabii ki de bir gün uyanın bir ev
görsem seni gibi kendimizi bir böcek
olarak bulmuyoruz ki yani belki
bulabiliriz teknoloji o kadar
evrimleşirse gördüğünüz gibi
teknolojisini tanımadığına inananlardan
biri de benim ama sınır demişken
gerçekten günümüzde bunun Ben etik
değerler bile yapay zekanın çok fazla
kısıtlandığını Veya en azından çoğu
bilim insanı tarafından sorgulandığını
Düşünüyorum şimdi şöyle ki
gerçekten de Yapay Zeka şu an günümüzde
hiç az bir sayı değil 3.3 milyon iş
gücünün yerini Tutabilecek potansiyelde
ama şimdi şöyle bir şey var ki güç her
zaman iyi ve kötüyle birlikte gelir yani
dengesi gibi aslında ama asla teknoloji
iyi veya kötü değildir bunu kullanan
insan iyi veya kötüdür ve Sonuçta biz bu
değişimin şimdiki zamanında temsil
ediyoruz
ve bizim dolayısıyla da El Ele verip hep
beraber geleceğimizi teknolojiyi iyiye
kullanarak şekillendirmeniz gerekiyor
hemen gerçekten birleşmiş milletlerin
ben kendim de geçen hafta Slime diye
Pardon diye Avrupa'nın en prestijli
konferanslarından birinde oturum başka
böyle yapıyordum envarıyorum yani
çevrede komitesinde ve Gerçekten bu
kadar çevre komitesi diyorum ben size
ama İnanır mısınız
bilmiyorum en çok teknoloji kullanan
komitelerden birisiydi
iydi şöyle gördüğünüz gibi biz tüm
işlerimizi üyelerden bilgisayardan Hatta
data analizlerinden makine
algoritmalarına vesaire
ve Gerçekten ben çok küçük bir overmiş
gibi gelebiliyor ama Yapay Zeka Market
alışverişinden böyle kulüp
aktivitelerine veya uzay çalışmalarına
kadar gerçekten çok büyük bir şey yani
teknolojiyi Ben aslında içi çiçeklerle
dolu bir bahçeye benzetiyorum Herkes
kendi denetimi farklı oluşturuyor
kimilerinin iyice soluyor Kimileri ki
yeni açıyor ama hepsinin ortak noktası
yeşeren bir toplum geliştirmesi
gerçekten de ve şöyle bir şey var
Gerçekten
bunu gördüm delegeler kendi Aralarında
konuşuyorlar ve ben buna kulak misafiri
oldum ya Birisi sisteme girerse benim ne
kadar konuştuğumu değiştirirse ona göre
benim Ödüm değişir mi şimdi bu tabi çok
basit bir kaygı kalıyor dünyamızda
yapılabilecek yapay zekayla olunca şey
arasında
Bunlar gerçekten çok önemli konular ve
tüm dünyayı tüm yaşamımızı günlük
yaşamımızda dahil olmak üzere çok fazla
değiştirebilecek bir kavram olduğunu ben
düşünüyorum Burada gerçekten
teknolojinin Sizin için de ifade ettiği
çok önemli
diye bir söz vardır Ben bunu çok severim
şimdi bu benim için çok büyük bir şey
ifade ediyor Çünkü günümüzde bu kadar
değişen bir toplumda liderlere çok fazla
ihtiyacımız var Ama öncelikle Lider
nedir Lider kesinlikle ben emian
Kulübü'nün başkanıyım Yeter artık as
başkanı
genel sekreterim gibi bir şey olamaz
çünkü liderler her zaman başkalarını
daha fazla yapmaya çağıran daha fazla
hayal kurmaya sınırlarını aşmaya çağıran
insanlardır Ben tabii ki burada size
çıkıp da ben hepinizi daha güzel bir
geleceğe davet ediyorum demiyorum Sadece
teknolojiyi Siz kendi hayatınızda nereye
koyuyorsunuz Bu gerçekten çok önemli bir
faktör yani sabah atılan Şuradaki top şu
an bana bakıyor sizlere bakıyor ama biz
o topa bakmayalım sadece
Biz o elimize alalım daha fazla aksiyon
alalım Gerçekten bu benim için çok
ve bunun teknolojinin iyi tarafını
kullanarak yapalım yani ben size dediğim
gibi teknolojiyi Deva Hem sadece beyaz
beyaz siyah değil iyi veya kötü değil
Bunu Önemli olan bizim kendi nasıl
kullandığınız ve size Az önce
bahsettiğim gibi eşime
are you
diyorum ki bugün benim kozmozumu kendi
kozmozumu dinlerken Sizler zevk
almışsınızdır Umarım siz de kendi
kozmozunuzu bulmuşsunuzdur veya
bulacaksınızdır Ama mutlaka
kozmozlarınızı insanlara anlatırken
böyle platformlarda paylaşırken
sesimizin duyulduğuna emin olun ve
fikirlerinizi paylaşmaktan asla
çekinmeyin bunu yaparken de teknolojiyi
güzel bir şekilde kullanın dilerim
benimlediğiniz için
[Alkış]